hallo ihr lieben ich freue mich richtig
auf das rezept heute denn wir machen
heute total leckere brownies die sind
richtig saftig also fast genauso wie
sein müssen jetzt jemand angestellt wir
machen gleich weiter
kaum hat man das wort brownie das schild
an der tür
also will machen heute richtig leckere
saftige schokobraun es ist eine art
basis rezept denn am ende könnt ihr
alles daran geben was sie möchte von
müssen bis marshmallows alles was sie
möchten und die zutaten
das ist allerbeste die habt ihr mit
sicherheit alles zu hause und jetzt
zeige ich euch die ersten mal und zwar
benötigen wir zeit bitter kuvertüre
butter mehl zucker etwas vanille zucker
oder vanille extrakt und ein wenig kakao
so ihr lieben die zubereitung ist
einfach und kompliziert aber ihr habt
zwei möglichkeiten da können jetzt
einfach auswählen
wir müssen nämlich im ersten schritt
kuvertüre butter und zucker sorten
schmelzen entweder in einem topf auf
niedriger stufe oder wenn ihr auf nummer
sicher gehen möchte wie ich dann macht
ihr einfach ein wasserbad weil ihr wisst
kuvertüre und butter das sind so
kandidat die brennen einfach schnell an
und dann ärgert man sich im nachhinein
deshalb habe ich jetzt ein wasserbad
einfach wasser in einem topf aufkochen
lassen anschließend auf niedriger hitze
gestellt und eine große schüssel in
ausreichend große schüssel darüber
gegeben und wichtig ist dass auch das
wasser den topf nicht berührt
[Musik]
nach wenigen minuten ist die masse schön
geschmolzen und im nächsten schritt
müssen wir das ganze abkühlen lassen ca
20 minuten lang denn gleich kommen die
eier rein und falls ihr das nicht ab
kündigt dann werden die eierstöcke und
man hat die ruhe und das schmeckt nun
wirklich nicht lecker nach 20 minuten
ist die schoko masse nur noch lauwarm
und jetzt können wir nach und nach die
eier hinzugeben wichtig ist das ja ein
schneebesen benutzt und kein
handrührgerät denn mit dem handrührgerät
würdet ihr noch unnötig luft rein
schlagen und dann ist ja nicht mehr
schön saftig
[Musik]
das sieht schon richtig lecker aus aber
uns fehlt für die bindung natürlich
jetzt noch mehl und der mit extra
schokoladig werte bei kakao und nimmt
dann nicht den trinker das muss wirklich
bacau sein falls ihr keinen da habt
könnt ihr das auch durch weitere zeit
bitterschokolade ersetzen aber das
schreibe ich euch noch mal ganz genau in
die infobox
[Musik]
die trockenen zutaten die sie sich immer
ganz gerne damit keine klümpchen
entstehen und backpulver dürfte hier
nicht rein geben weil wir wollen ja
nicht dass unser braun die hoch geht
sondern wir wollen dass er richtig schön
saftig bleibt das würde ich jetzt noch
gut ein und dann ist der teig fertig
[Musik]
so unser basis teilt für richtig leckere
schokobraun ist jetzt fertig faltet die
frage kommen kann ich dann nüsse reintun
oder auch andere zutaten gerne gerne
also jetzt in dem fall einfach hier mit
in den teig anrühren und dann in europa
vom einführen das rezept ist für eine
ganz normale brownie backform ausgelegt
die sind immer 20 x 20 cm groß falls sie
keinen da hat so wie ich nicht einfach
euren ba kram den habe ich jetzt hier
auf 17 x 23 cm eingestellt das
funktioniert auch die backzeit ist kann
ich euch auch schon mal sagen liegt bei
160 grad ober und unterhitze circa 35
minuten
[Musik]
ohne witz der teig der glänzt mehr als
für manchen highlighter
guck dir das meine jetzt richtig
glücklich was auch immer einfach ist
aber richtig hübsch auf jeden fall
nach dem backen einfach nur noch
auskühlen lassen und dann könnt ihr sie
genießen wobei noch nicht mal auskühlen
lassen
die schmecken auch lauwarm richtig
richtig lecker als warme rot braun
mitzumischen sahne obendrauf ich habe
das jetzt auch mit sahne serviert und
wie gesagt das ist eine basis rezept ihr
könnt alles mögliche noch rein mission
in den teig und dann einfach nur
genießen falls ich das rezept gefallen
hat dann freue ich mich sehr über eure
fotos mit dem hashtag die skizzen auf
instagram schaut in die infobox dastehen
genaue mengenangaben noch mal für euch
drin
ansonsten könnt ihr diesem video gerne
einen deutlichen nach oben da lassen
main kanal kostenlos abonnieren dann
verpasst ja auch nichts mehr
und dann freue ich mich aufs nächste mal
tschüss
[Musik]